i got to give a big congratulations to
disney you have united the internet
through hate yes
but united nonetheless
[Music]
so pinocchio is the disney live-action
version of pinocchio in the same year
that guillermo del toro's pinocchio's
coming out and this being the disney
live-action version of the animated
disney pinocchio you can bet and you
would be right that it's the disney safe
zone version of disney's pinocchio not
that it doesn't have standouts in terms
of charm we'll get those out of the way
right now well tom hanks
i mean he was fine i actually was
shocked at how much he actually did look
like geppetto he brought a vulnerability
to gepetto i really liked that but tom
hanks having a very lucrative
relationship with disney in the past as
well as robert zemeckis who directed
this movie it really feels like someone
ran into tom hanks on the disney lot it
was like oh hey you want to get into
makeup and film for i don't know a day
the easiest paycheck of your life i
suppose it's a testament to tom hanks's
talent having it feel like that yet
having him still be a standout course a
testament to the lack of quality of the
film in general there's that angle too
also jiminy cricket easily the best
character in the movie i was like that
sounds just like jiminy cricket who
voices is joseph gordon levitt
i guess jgl can just do a really good
jiminy cricket voice i didn't know and
with jiminy cricket it is a case of
keeping the soul of the character but
updating some of the jokes just for the
times the rest of the movie falls in two
camps one adds new stuff that feels like
it serves no other purpose than to pad
the run time to make this movie a half
an hour longer than the animation was or
two does exactly what the animation did
just doesn't do it nearly as well and
that's the biggest bummer of all of this
dude pinocchio let's just address it
it's scary as [ __ ] the disney animated
pinocchio film is probably the main
reason i never talked to strangers it
scared the living piss out of me last
month when i watched it honest john that
weird cat he hangs out with you really
felt like if you talk to a stranger when
you're walking home from school it's
gonna end very badly sells pinocchio
into servitude to stromboli if you go to
pleasure island you don't listen to your
conscience do whatever your heart
desires obviously you're gonna turn into
a donkey and get sold to the salt mines
of hell granted all of that stuff from
the disney animated movie happens to
pinocchio in this disney live-action
version but to that i gotta say the
devil's in the details the animation
just had a little more made it a little
darker had scenarios that just amplified
the fear factor pinocchio being about
listening to your conscience consequence
to action it's always been a tale of
morality and consequence in that i feel
like consequences should be scary
otherwise why not do them like a
conversation with alexander you remember
alexander the old donkey kid who could
still talk so you can talk
yes sir i wanna go home to my mama stuff
like that just makes a horrid situation
feel that much worse but in this disney
live-action pinocchio disney does what
disney does best and that is play it
safe i know some people don't like it
when people compare a new version of
something to the original but with
disney live action movies i feel like it
is fundamentally different because the
disney live action versions are
essentially translations of their own
work and if the modern live-action
version can't do what the old version
did for one reason or another and only
comes across as giving less than the
animated version gave then the argument
is should they have even done it at all
essentially what you're dealing with is
the difference between a glass of orange
juice and a glass of really watered down
diluted orange juice it's like why not
just take the glass of orange juice it
is just everything that is but better
and that's what this pinocchio is it's
diluted it's the nerf version of
pinocchio i suppose that can be a
positive dislike if you don't like
really strong acidic drinks you might
take the diluted orange juice if you
have really young children the old
pinocchio animation would traumatize
them well you have a nerfed version of
that so you can show them this instead
we're talking about things that aren't
as frightening you look at monstro like
the sound design to monstro
[Music]
it was just
scary noises man right this doesn't have
that he just essentially swings around
opens his mouth
and let's face it he looks like shark to
puss you get some of the catchy tunes
from the animation in here but not all
of them that song has been in my head
for a day and a half straight hi diddly
dee
an actor's life for me and in me being
grumpy old man jeremy wearing his grumpy
old man energy on his sleeves i think
some of the lessons in this movie are
just bad lessons i'm gonna file this
under spoiler-ish but i mean we're
talking about a movie translation of an
animated movie that's been out for
decades and although it goes down a
little differently in this movie than it
did the animation that's kind of the
point of me talking about it i'm just
saying the spoiler warning it doesn't
really matter it's just a courtesy he's
lying his nose is growing and he has to
get the key to the cage and so he tells
another lie so his nose can get the key
and it gets the key the lesson there if
you lie enough you can get what you need
that just seems like a bad lesson in the
end this disney live-action pinocchio
version of the animated pinocchio movie
is the gold standard of
why did that need to happen it's
essentially rehashing the same beats
from the animated movie but not doing it
as well or concise as the animated movie
did feels like a robot watched pinocchio
and was like i can make this into a
movie and dead and it has all the soul
that you would think that would have i
gotta say in my review of barbarian i do
apologize i said the wrong skarsgard
name i said alexander not bill i knew it
was bill i knew it was pennywise not the
northmen i knew it wasn't eric northman
from true blood i knew it was pennywise
i just for some odd reason i said
alexander
it happens but it will happen again it
might happen tomorrow for this movie
because i'm not going to remember this
movie in t minus one day yup already
forgot it is ironic that the story of a
puppet boy who wants to be a real boy is
a story that has no real soul whatsoever
i chuckle at that kind of irony all
right so pinocchio have you seen it or
did you grow up on the old animated
version did you scare the piss out of
youtube whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you